[Music]
Disney Channel pays tribute to Cameron
Boyce following the premiere of
descendants three it was an emotional
night on Friday
Cameron's co-stars texted the late actor
ahead of the film's premiere dove
Cameron shared a photo of the group chat
with co-stars Sophia Carson and booboo
Stewart all writing I love you so much
dov also shared a moving
behind-the-scenes clip from the third
descendants the cast embracing on the
film's sound stage with it she wrote a
heartfelt lengthy post that read in part
six years one family we love you Cameron
Cameron Sophia Carson Cameron Boyce and
booster following the premiere Disney
Channel aired a tribute to Cameron Boyce
containing interviews bloopers and
behind-the-scenes clips
Kameron boys died in his sleep from a
seizure on July 6th his family later
told ET the 20 year old suffered from
epilepsy Cameron said we can't take it
with us so it's about what you leave and
and with this I promise Cameron that I
will carry this goodness with me in all
the days of my life
ET recently spoke with descendants 3
director Kenny Ortega about Cameron's
legacy everything that Cameron's in he
brings the light every every room that
he walked into every cause that he that
he you know pushed for and everything
that he ever did I mean he was it was
impossible not to be drawn into him
that's how I found him I fell in love
with him when he was doing Jesse and I
went after him for descendants oh yes oh
yes and so descendants 3 you know again
we'll just remind everybody of his
incredible gift you know he was
bioluminescent he was lit from the
inside out he really was and and we will
miss him but we will carry his legacy
forward